Which of the triangles, triangle
DEF, triangle GHI, and triangle
JKL, are similar
to triangle ABC?
And we have this triangle ABC.
They've given us, or they've
just marked one of the angles,
and then they've given the
lengths of the two sides
on either side of that angle.
And you might remember
from geometry class,
you can prove that
two triangles are
similar if you can show they
have corresponding congruent
angles.
So let's say we're
trying to compare
this triangle to this triangle,
triangle JKL to triangle ABC.
So if you can show that they
have two corresponding angles
that are congruent
to each other,
and that the sides on
either side, the ratio
between the sides on either
side of that angle are the same,
then you're going to be dealing
with a similar triangle.
So, for example, if we say
that this angle corresponds
to this angle, and
they've already
marked it to say that
they're congruent,
so that's a pretty
good starting point.
And if we could show that
the ratio between this side
and this side, side KL is the
same as the ratio between BA
and KJ, then we can
say that these two
are similar triangles.
Now you might be
thinking, well, how
did I decide to compare
BC to KL and BA to KJ?
Well, both of these are the two
sides that essentially make up
this angle, and BC is
the shorter of the two.
These are the two sides
that make up this angle,
both of these are the,
I guess you could say,
they're segments
of the rays, there
are parts of the rays that
make up this angle if you were
to continue forever, and the
blue one is the shorter one,
so that's the best candidate.
KL is the best candidate
to correspond to BC.
Well in order to do
this, we're going
to figure out the
lengths of these sides.
We're going to have
to do it for all
of these triangles
right over here.
And they don't give
us the lengths,
but this thing is sitting
on a coordinate plane.
Now you could use
the distance formula,
but I like to just
cut the chase.
The distance formula is based
on the Pythagorean theorem,
and they've drawn a grid
right over here for us,
so we could just set up some
right triangles to figure out,
we could make each
of these sides
essentially the hypotenuse
of right triangles.
So to figure out
the length of KJ,
we could set up this right
triangle right over here.
This height is 3, this
length right over here
we could count it, it's 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9 units wide.
If we couldn't
count like that, we
could say, look,
we're going from x
equals negative 6 to x
equals 3, 3 minus negative 6
is equal to 9.
Let me make that clear.
And that's essentially where
the distance formula comes from,
3 minus negative 6.
You're finding the change,
your change in x and you're
going to square it, and then
you have your change in y,
you're going to
square it, and that's
going to be equal to
this hypotenuse squared.
So let's think
about-- so this is
going to be equal
to the square root.
I'm just using the
Pythagorean theorem here.
So [? that line, ?]
I'll just call it so K,
let me just write it out,
so that you don't think
I'm doing some type of voodoo.
So 3 squared plus-- let
me do it a little higher,
because I have a
feeling I'm going
to use a lot of real estate--
3 squared plus 9 squared
is equal to the
length of KJ squared.
3 squared is 27, sorry,
not 27, 3 squared is 9.
9 squared is 81, and
then that's going
to be equal to the
length of KJ squared.
Or, we get KJ squared
is equal to 90,
which is the same
thing as 9 times 10.
And so KJ is going to
be-- it's the square root
of this, so the
square root of that
is going to be the
square root of 9 times 10
is equal to the
square root of 9 times
the square root of 10, which is
equal to 3 square roots of 10.
So it's actually the
exact same length as BA.
Now let's do the
same thing for KL.
For KL we could set up another
right triangle right over here.
So Its height is 3
and its width is 3.
This is 3 and 3 right over here.
So we could write 3
squared plus 3 squared
is equal to the
length of KL squared.
This right over here is
18 is equal to KL squared,
and if you take the
square root of both sides
18 is, of course, 9 times 2.
So this right over here,
this is the square root of 18
is equal to KL.
Square root of 18
is the same thing
as square root of
9 times 2, that's
just 3 square roots of 2.
This is equal to 3
square roots of 2.
So this is 3 square roots of 2.
This is 3 square roots of 10.
This angle is congruent to
this angle right over here.
So not only are ABC and JKL,
not only are they similar,
but these are actually
congruent triangles.
These are congruent
triangles right over here,
but all congruent triangles
are going to be similar.
So this one this one
is definitely similar.
JKL is similar to ABC.
Now let's figure out all
of these lengths up here.
Well you have,
let's see, this is 1
and 1, so you could say
1 squared plus 1 squared
is equal to EF squared, is equal
to the length of segment EF
squared.
Or you could say EF is equal
to-- Let's see, this is 2,
so this is going to be
the square root of 2.
So actually I should have
done that in that blue color
because this will
be the shorter,
we want this to be the shorter
side if we're comparing the two
sides on either
side of that angle.
And now let's look at ED.
So once again, we can
set up a right triangle
that is 1 wide and 3 tall.
And so we could say
1 squared plus 3
squared is equal to the
length of ED squared.
1 squared plus 3 squared,
this is going to be 10.
So we get ED is equal to
the square root of 10.
Now is the ratio between BC
and EF the same as the ratio
between BA and ED?
So let's write this down.
So square root of 3,
or 3 square roots of 2
over square root
of 2 is equal to 3.
So the ratio between these two
blue sides between BC and EF
is 3.
The ratio between
these two orange sides
is 3 square roots of 10
over the square root of 10,
which is also 3.
So the ratio between these
two corresponding sides
are the same, the angle
in between is congruent,
so these two triangles
are also similar.
So DEF is also similar to ABC.
So we have one more
to think about.
So HI is a candidate to
be corresponding to BC.
What's its length?
Well, let's see, this
is a right triangle
that's width 2, height 2, so
we could write 2 squared plus 2
squared is equal to the
length of HI squared.
This is 4, this is 4, so
8 is equal to the length
of HI squared.
And then we can take the
square root of both sides.
So the square root of 8 is
equal to the length of HI,
or we could say the
length of HI is equal to,
let's see this is 4 times
2, so the square root
of 4 times the square root
of 2 is 2 square roots of 2.
So this is 2 square roots of 2.
And then the candidate to be
corresponding to AB is HG,
it's the longer of the two sides
on either side of this angle.
So HG, we can set up a right
triangle that looks like this.
It's 2 wide and 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6 high.
So we can write, and
let's scroll over
to the right a
little bit, we can
write that 2 squared
plus 6 squared
is equal to the
length of HG squared.
So let's see, this
is 4 plus 36 is
equal to the length
of HG squared.
Or we get that HG is equal
to the square root of 40.
Square root of 40, let's see,
how can we simplify that?
That's the same thing as the
square root of 4 times 10,
which is 2 times the
square root of 10.
So HG is equal to 2 times
the square root of 10.
Now let's compare the ratios.
The ratio between
BC and HI is going
to be 3 square roots of 2 over
2 square roots of 2, which
is 3/2.
And the ratio
between BA-- let me
do that in that orange color--
which is 3 square roots of 10,
and HG, which is 2 square
roots of 10, is also 3/2.
So all of these triangles, not
only are they similar to ABC,
but they're actually all
similar to each other.